ce paradis de la tomate et des saveurs a
failli ne pas ouvrir ses portes cette
année à cause du coronavirus la question
s'est posée mais a vite été balayée par
les organisateurs on pense que là ya
quand même peu de risques on a essayé de
l'encadrer maximum donc c'était
l'occasion ou jamais que les gens
puissent enfin vivre quelque chose de
plus réjouissant
on a des producteurs qui sont des gens
qui ne font qu'y font beaucoup de salons
de ce type ou de fêtes de ce type
donc pour eux là ça fait des mois qu'ils
travaillent pas plein en arrivant on
dira qu est-ce qu on est content d'être
là et les salons continue de s'annuler
les uns après les autres pour raisons
sanitaires
alors cette fête et pour les exposants
une aubaine c'est en train de sauver un
petit peu la saison parce que avec moins
de clients le panier moyen est quand
même supérieur
donc c'est quand même pour nous du
bonheur de travailler sur ces
manifestations d'automne les visiteurs
auraient envie de dépenser un peu plus
qu'avant pour se fournir en produits
locaux est bon pour la santé et mise à
part une minorité
ils n'ont pas peur d'être contaminés ici
pas du tout parce que babe comme vous le
voyez j'ai le masque les gens sont bien
protégés il ya les distances qui sont
respectés donc non c'est très bien moi
j'ai appris par mail qui avait entre
trois et six mille personnes sur deux
jours donc un petit peu mais bon ça se
passe bien
le château de la bourdaisière a même
accueilli plus de visiteurs que l'année
dernière avec une augmentation de 15%
pour la journée de samedi